okay so westworld season 4 episode 6
sets up the penultimate episode with a
couple of twists here and there as
always the show is filled with easter
eggs that call back to earlier episodes
and throughout this video we're going to
be breaking them all down we're also
finally going to get the answer as to
why so many of my subscribers are
leaving i'm just trying
to get away
from you
anyway we open in new york and see the
first meeting of frankie and jay at this
point the parasites have infected
everyone and the outliers like him have
started to question the nature of their
reality now we saw this heavily
throughout last week's episode with the
rescue mission carried out by the rebels
here we met lindsay who was seemingly
saved by jay though we'll get into the
truth of this later down the line now
they very much gave us the idea of how
the outliers slowly realize that
something is wrong with the world and
then the rebels have a short window to
pull them out i'm not sure how they
learn about this but they clearly have
some way to monitor the park and all its
systems it might just be a case of them
breaking their loops which we now know
are designed by christina now frankie
approaches jay and he brings up his
brother daniel turns out that he was an
outlier too who was taken away and this
memory was erased from his parents minds
this is very similar to maeve who had
the memory of her daughter removed after
her loop was changed however like maeve
jay still has flashes of him and because
of this it sets off several red flags in
the park surveillance frankie takes him
to her mother uaid who reveals that the
drones are coming to shut him down as
they try to get out the tower sounds off
and everyone freezes including a pair
having a picnic this reminded me a lot
of the nightmare we heard from maya
about how the flies swarmed her when she
was out with their family and
potentially this could be based off that
children sit in their swings with
ricketus grins and overall it's a creepy
scene that's made even worse by the
arrival of the drones clearly the
flights that they work on must have
hitched to ride as we see one appear out
of nowhere and attach itself to one of
the rebels imagery of flies crawling
across someone's face is something
that's popped up before and it happened
with dolores in season one as well as
jim navarro in this one you wait and co
make a break for it and we see how the
surroundings change for the rebels gone
are the pristine and spotless cities and
instead they hide out and run down homes
with broken fences and destroy trees
lots of matrix vibes here with this
being the real world and the city being
the simulation up the stairs we can also
catch a graffiti tag that says free free
will which calls back to the same
wording that was used outside caleb's
house frankie goes to her radio in an
attempt to reach out to her father which
we've seen her doing throughout the
season this becomes very important later
on and it's a routine she's carried out
for most of her life at this point she
also drops this line about wanting a
brother to which jay says i'm not your
brother
there's no point in leaving these
messages
your dad is gone
this ends up giving away the host
version of him later on who tries to act
overly nice whereas this guy's a bit of
it
from here we could have frankie and
menard who are currently escorting me to
temperance at this point bernard also
drops a very interesting line about
frankie you think you know a lot don't
you about you
i never quite know what you'll do next
now this means that she's truly an
outlier as it's impossible to predict
what she's gonna do this was murdering
caleb during season three and the reason
that sorak basically had him reformatted
is because rehoboam was unable to
predict his actions now with her being
the child of an outlier she isn't really
in the system as he was unpredictable so
therefore his offspring would be too
potentially rehoboam was used as part of
the way to infect people with the
parasites and the outliers in that may
also be carried over as outliers here
now after the title sequence we cut to a
memory of caleb and frankie holding
hands as they walk through a field
together we later see how this happy
memory inspires the recreation of caleb
to push further than he's ever gone
before this idea of walking through a
field holding hands with a daughter
figure is of course something that's
also been reflected in maeve we do have
visions of their doing this in the
recent entries and the sublime itself is
also a golden field like what we have
here at this point though hale tells him
to wake up this is something that she
later repeats at the end and it very
much starts a new loop for her to study
caleb
wake up now this is revealed to be a
game which caleb actually guesses
instantly where the hell are we now
[Music]
playing another one of your games
charlotte mocks him for constantly
bringing up his daughter and she says
he's not the only person who lost
someone this is likely referring to the
real charlotte's child and x in season 3
who ended up being killed whilst she
survived she's desperate to know why so
many of the hosts send their own lives
when they come into contact with
outliers and it makes sense why she
instructs them not to talk with those
that become targets however hope did as
did william and slowly they seem to come
to the realization that they don't find
enjoyment in torturing humans they're
better than us and would also rather die
than be at the mercy of hail it
basically just says that they'd rather
no longer exist than be stuck inside
this prison of her making that chains
both the humans and also the hosts she
wants to see if this can provide any
insight and as caleb refuses to talk she
has to concoct this plan she even plants
the idea that frankie is alive in his
head which sends him off on his quest if
you won't tell me
maybe your daughter will now the booth
that they're in amongst the cylindrical
structures is also very similar to the
one that james delos was stuck inside
during the fidelity test there's further
nodes to this with a version of caleb
that's cut up his own face during season
two both elsie and benard came across a
variant of him that it scratched away at
his face too echoing the horror that we
see here hail is also wearing all black
which is the same color that william
used to have on when he went to run
through tests with delos as hell exits
the room she presses a control panel
with 278 written on it which is a nice
little detail as she brings 279 in at
the end now she enfrosts the glass and
at this point we see the other calyps
this hint towards how further along they
are due to the quote-unquote hourglass
and where the sand is in it the more
they deteriorate the more they start to
self-harm and this system moves in a
circular motion to place the oldest and
newest in cases beside each other now
hill also self-harms throughout by
scratching her arm however i don't think
that this show she's deteriorating more
so it's calling back to season 3 in
which she used to do the same thing the
beat up caleb then tells him how to
escape and he also hints to the other
loops i only know
well i told me
now caleb discovers a needle in the
hourglass that knocks him unconscious
the drone comes in and attempts to
incinerate him but he manages to escape
i'm guessing all this is what plays on
the credit scene namely how it ends
similar to what we have here we had
several people inside cylinders that
ended up burning which i think this
scene is meant to hint towards in
caleb's dream he recalls how he met you
aid which is where maeve left him she
realized that he'd found happiness annie
wade is revealed to be his nurse this
was actually hinted at when they dropped
him off due to her fixing his trip
there's a great cut of the torch being
cut with a creepy creepy drone i'll be
honest i woke up to worse she tried to
kill me too you having that
[Music]
anyway caleb escapes through event in
the floor and it begins again that's
hinted towards judo and arrow being
scratched on the metal in the bottom he
finds a ben corpse along with ashes
which are the ones who weren't lucky
enough to make it through this part cut
to temperance which is now completely
run down and covered in dust this
actually appeared as a vision to bernard
when he was in the sublime and other
moments in that had the hoover dam
servers heading towards where his quest
may be going they pass a shop called the
oyster bar and if you cast your mind
back to episode 4 this is actually where
maeve and caleb led charlotte past when
they made a break for it we can also
catch the butterfly tavern in the
background and in westworld this was
called the mariposa which translates to
butterfly now using the same service
elevator that maven co escaped out of
bernard leads frankie down into a hidden
floor which was used as a game itself
this was one of the main places that was
used to create the super spreaders and
bernard says that this place wasn't
built to last hale and william had it
thrown up to attract people and rather
than being something they could run for
a long time they used it as a front to
enact their own game they find what i
believe is the fake hector and pull out
his pearl as a way to duplicate maeve i
love this detail as hector of course
saved maeve at several points during the
earlier seasons so having him be the one
who also brings her back is a nice
carryover now bernard starts the host
tank up and now this might be a reach i
got a lot of flashes here when he used
to work for the synthetic meat farm back
in episode 3. i think at the time they
purposely used that iconography to show
how bernard had moved from one synthetic
meat form to the next and it's sort of
like poetry they rhyme now they start to
resurrect her in the butterfly tavern
which too has a lot of symbolism as it's
where maeve was reborn in westworld when
her loop was changed whereas westworld
used to monitor and copy people's brains
through using the hats hale developed a
much faster way in order to copy guests
in this park that wasn't designed to
have a long lifespan hidden behind
mirrors these monitored people and
helped her make duplicates which
explains why she was able to easily
create copies of other people bernard
also says the phrase through the looking
glass and not to alice in wonderland
that was too brought up in the matrix to
talk about going on the other side of
the mirror in alice in wonderland this
was meant to signify someone passing
into another world which mirrors the
jewel ones that we have in this season
now using the tech in it they'll be able
to copy maver cross quicker and at the
poker table they put her into hector
after hiding the pills bernard starts to
fix maeve with a pen that was used to
heal the hosts in westworld frankie
compares this to taking care of her own
mother who couldn't get medical
attention due to the world being overrun
by machines at this point the rest of
the group arrive in the dropship similar
to the one that sorak used to fly in i
couldn't see it for a while but it's
there if you look close enough it's yeah
sometimes sometimes the jokes are pretty
now the big mystery around this part of
the episode revolves around which one of
the rebels is a host however if you were
paying attention last week then you'll
know that it was jay because he was the
only one that went off on his own they
suspect that someone leaked their attack
to hell which is thought to be bernard
he says it's complicated and due to him
not knowing he was swapped out he likely
did do this because of what it would
lead to remember bernard is basically a
version of rehoboam at this point that's
constantly working the angles in order
to get on a path in which humanity ends
up saved now a bit of a theory time
theory time theory time but i think he
likely leaked the info to hell and then
she leaked the news about the outliers
to the rebels so that they could come
and get lindsay out hell could then swap
out whichever one broke off and she
likely had copies of all the people
going in now going forward as mentioned
earlier bernard's vision could end up
leading him to the hoover dam which is
where all the data from westworld was
kept in service by the original hail
haloris wants to access this but she
doesn't have the passwords however a
person who may is bernard because he
gained access to it at the end of season
3. in the sublime there would be a copy
of hell because she accessed the park
and thus this could have ended up
telling him he also of course has the
ability to run through every possibility
so potentially he'd already be like you
know be able to just work out the
passwords now this place would also have
a copy of caleb due to him doing
training exercises as part of the army
so now that the pieces have fallen in
place for frankie delane haddad is
somewhat alive and out there it might
end up leading to the group going there
next why not though and as always that's
the end of your time your time here time
also if you want a t-shirt with theory
time on it which why don't you we've set
up a merch store where you can buy loads
of brands like that just hand over your
money don't ask questions don't think
too much and wear some amazing theory
time clothes that will make people
attracted to you they will fancy you
link is in the description baby give me
a rent
anyway frankie shoots bernard runs up
the others and holds both the hosts
hostage at this point bernard basically
goes through the possibilities of people
that could be the mole and how in some
realities it's different members of the
group as we've kind of touched upon this
is because hale would have swapped out
whoever went off but bernard couldn't
have known for definite jain forces the
feelings of paranoia but i would have
just been like hey mate remember that
time you didn't like and subscribe and
if you said yeah i'd know it wasn't you
because you always do she suspects her
girlfriend a bit after she doesn't know
why she's resurrecting maeve and also
when she probes about where her brain is
back with caleb we watch as he makes his
way through the olympiad building we
even see the room hail tested for
fidelity in as well as a drone working
on the host processing unit that the one
we meet at the end is currently being
made in he ends up fighting this beast
but not before discovering some clues
that this has all happened before there
are several handprints on the walls a
cupboard full of his clothes along with
more wedding rings than elizabeth taylor
hey having that one for the dads now
this is hinted at being a game again by
how relaxed tale is when we cut to her
in the next scene with clementine she's
just waiting for it to play out and she
looks at the chair which in respect is
her just waiting for the whole thing to
culminate rather than wondering where
caleb is clementine also refers to the
people as sheep which calls back to
earlier in the season when hell called
them livestock by doing his best john
mcclane impression caleb crawls through
the vents and he comes face to face with
a version of himself on the floor or two
others which you can actually tell a lot
by looking at the bloodstains when using
his doppelganger to cushion his fall the
duplicate ends up with a similar blood
pattern to the one that seems localized
showing how these prior two likely came
down together caleb finally makes it to
the roof and back in temperance jay
gives himself away by saying this
you're my family see
you're like a sister to me it leads to a
big fight whilst caleb sends out his
message to frankie really emotional
scene in which we can see him shaking as
he starts to break down he delivers a
very important line here that also hints
towards why hosts are taking themselves
out rather than staying under hail's
control this world
humane is
it's live
what you have is
is real
i really think it's a case of the hosts
realizing that even though they've
escaped everything they're still stuck
in his manufactured reality caleb could
have resisted the parasite because he
had something real he lived off-grid
didn't seem that materialistic and
wasn't really a slave to the societal
systems that most humans were calling
back to the other point before if the
parasites are artificial they may have
been created using elements of rehoboam
to control people which again he's not
really part of i think the reasoning
behind how they work will be a big point
of contention and who knows they might
not even bother explaining it i think
they're just in the same way that
midichlorians weren't really needed to
explain how the force works that we
don't really need it in the case of the
parasites now the radio message somewhat
reaches frankie and though she doesn't
hear all of it it's enough to let her
know that her father is somewhat alive
she of course also met maeve when she
was a child and she saves her from host
j now they're likely going to be heading
to new york next and i do think that
maeve will be able to destroy the tower
due to her setting off the miniature one
in temperance this sent the hosts into
agony and i think she'll end up going
there next or she could head out to the
dam either way i'm loving this season so
far and we close out with a great ending
in which hale kills the caleb that we've
been following this episode hale ends up
wiping out all the other ones through
using fire which is similar to how james
dallas was finally exterminated she
returns to the room to find caleb
hunched over like he'd just been shot
and once more she tells him to wake up
the fidelity test will then continue
which ties into the title of this
episode this idea of a loop is of course
seen in caleb however it's also very
much seen in hail too though she's
completely unaware of it she's actually
going through her own lupiere she
continues this exercise once more
probably in the hopes of getting a
different result or learning more about
what's going on it's completely helpless
and a big waste of time but she keeps
doing it because she needs answers this
has been reflected in a lot of other
characters namely william who kept going
back to the park on this continuous loop
in hopes of getting to the center of the
maze really is a great way to end it
showing that all the hosts are stuck in
cycles whether they believe it or not
just in the same way that hail
self-harms the other hoes that come
across the outliers do too and yet she's
unable to understand why they do it hale
herself spends a lot of time with the
outliers but she can't grasp what's
going on with them which makes for an
excellent way to wrap up this entry and
we just have two episodes left and i
can't wait to see what happens with them
but in the meantime i'd love to hear
your thoughts as a thank you you'll be
entered into a competition where we're
giving away three copies of doctor
strange in the multiverse of madness on
the 15th of august all you have to do to
be with a chance of winning is like the
video make sure you subscribe with
notifications on and drop a comment
below with your thoughts on the episode
we pick the comments at random at the
end of the month and the winners of the
last one are on screen right now so if
that's you then message me on twitter at
heavyspoilers if you want someone else
to watch then make sure you check out
our writing of the last episode which
will be linked on screen right now lots
of cool easter eggs in that lots of
different theories as well so definitely
go head over there right after this
without the way thanks for sticking
through the video i've been paul i'll
see you next time take care peace